my six years of training and hard work
finally ended in 2019
when i got lances to be a pharmacist
i took two courses from simply learn
brings to an introduction to data
analytics which helped me become a
dynamic pharmacist
hi my name is dominic and i'm a
pharmacist at the university of nana
medical center
assigned to the woman and trainer unit
of the hospital i always wanted to
perform multiple roles as a pharmacist
since i've managed the ailt and diabetic
clinic at my previous facility
i wanted a course that could keep me up
to date on the latest technologies in
this way i could see each client as a
project and tackle their problems to
help them
the prince2 course that simply an office
is cost effective and the official exam
is part of the fees
and that is exactly what i needed the
reviews that i saw from other learners
were very compelling
after both certifications
i found a positive impact on my approach
to work
i implemented these two concepts while
handling the hiv pharmacy and clients
and learn to calculate risk while
designing a project
in an era where information is power and
data currency
the data analysis course taught me how
to gather and interpret data
so that i can implement the right
solutions for my clients
i'm also keen on starting a research
project and i'm sure that these
certifications will be very helpful
the medical food is very vast and
keeping up can sometimes be challenging
to manage working studies i plan the
topics that i want to complete at the
beginning of every week
i have designated my evenings for
studies and also tried to make time for
my friends and hobbies planning has
really helped me to carve out some time
for myself to read
watch football and sometimes basketball
too to all aspiring professionals
being dynamic versatile and innovative
is very important and upskilling is a
key to that
ask ourselves to be a better
professional and help inspire others by
helping them to achieve their goals